Good morning everyone. I am John Palfrey
and on behalf of the steering committee thank you for
being here and most importantly, thank you to Doron and Peter
and the founding sponsors of the Digital Public Library of America.
That was an announcement of $5 million for the next 18 months or so.
[Applause] there are many things exciting about this
effort mostly I think the extraordinary gathering of
people from so many walks of life
and places this morning gathered around the idea that attracts us.
I think one central concept important to note is there
was a lot of talk in Washington about public and private partnerships.
It seems this is the embodiment of the really good one.
We just heard about $5 million on top of the previous million dollars in private capital
being contributed to an ad hoc group of all of us.
We are the DPLA.
To work together in a way we haven't before.
That joins not just us as citizens of the United States and elsewhere
and international partners as we would hear later today,
but also our federal government which has an unprecedented way stepped up
and said we want to participate in this likely crazy
thing. As the chair of the steering committee,
I can say I have been blown away by the extent to which our federal agencies and state
and local government agencies have held up their hands to say let's work together on this.
An amazing realm of people on their steering committee and the three people
we are about to hear from now in this report from Washington.
I'm going to go down the line
and we will hear in this report from Washington from three great friends
and some of the best friends of the Digital Public
Library of America effort. First Deanna Marcum, the associate librarian of Congress.
We've heard reference to the Library of Congress which
has a central role to play in these efforts for many years
and have been a leader in the digitization of our nations heritage.
I believe 28 million objects have been digitized by the
Library of Congress as an important centerpiece in what
we have to work with the more important is the human capital that Deanna Marcum
and her team have brought to this effort.
We are grateful for all you have done
and look forward to hearing from you this morning.
Thank you very much. Is -- in the room?
I have to check to see if she is in the room before I
tell you the Library of Congress is the largest most
comprehensive library in the world.
There is some debate about that.
In the collection of the Library of Congress there are
148 million items, we have digitized 28 million of those.
I liked Peter's comment about moving from boutique to the
Wal-Mart model because what I think this initiative
allows is even though we have digitized a lot of material,
it isn't enough to be the kind of digital resource we all believe it's important for the country so we see this as
an opportunity to expand
and enhance the work we have already done.
I am filling in today for the librarian of Congress.
If he were here,
I think he would want you to know a little bit more about
what we have done already
and then we can talk together about how we can leverage
what we have done to meet these needs.
The mission of the Library of Congress is to support
Congress in fulfilling its constitutional duties
and to further the progress of knowledge
and creativity for the benefit of the American people.
It is not unlike the NEH mission,
unlike the missions you will hear about here.
The point is what we are concerned about is making these
resources that have been amassed at a great institution
by tax dollars from American citizens
and we want to make that is available as possible.
That is what brings us to the table of the digital public
Library of America.
It appears to be the kind of opportunity that will help
us fulfill our mission in a very important way.
Let me go into a little detail about what we have done.
We have a long history of building Digital collections.
It began in 1987 when Dr. Billington was appointed to the Library of Congress.
He went on a tour of the country of town hall meetings in
10 locations throughout the country. He asked,
what do you want from the Library of Congress?
He met with teachers and librarians and faculty in universities
and pretty much the answer was uniformly the same.
We want your content and we want to where we are,
not where you are. He took that to heart
and he came back to the Library of Congress with the
notion of what we must do is make our content more widely accessible.
The Internet hadn't been invented by anyone yet so we
looked to CD-ROM technology to get content out
and we began digitizing collections in the very early 1990s.
We focused on materials that would be focused on the K-12
community because that's where we thought the greatest
need was. We were sending CD-ROMs to schools
and libraries. We had 44 pilot institutions
and we went back to all of them to find out how they were
using the content so we could understand what else we should try to digitize.
What was amazing to everyone involved is when we thought
this would be most useful to high school students,
in fact, all the way down to third grade,
students were making innovative uses of this digital
content and we saw even with this CD-ROM method,
students were beginning to ask important questions about
their history and about the world.
We committed to making more and more of our primary source materials available to
schools and libraries around the country.
In 1995, talked with the Library of Congress about this
digitization effort and said if you will raise private money,
we will put up some money.
There was a three to one match with a three-part private
and one part Congress but that allowed us to expand our digitization efforts.
We realized we had special collections that were held
nowhere else in the country. We had manuscripts and music and maps and film
and all kinds of things so we began to focus on
digitizing those special collections of materials rather than books.
We were visited by Google when Google began to digitize collections.
We decided our focus would be on special formats
and we did a little bit of experimenting but in the end,
we stayed with our primary focus. More recently,
we have begun to think far more broadly about what from
our collections should be readily accessible to the American people.
We were pleased with the Sloan foundation agreed to fund
a digitization project that would allow us to identify
public domain books and our general collections
and make those available through a website as well.
We were founded for two years by the Sloan foundation
and we have been able to continue the books digitization
effort with there own funds but we are systematically
going through our American history, local history and genealogy collections
and putting those online as well.
Before I lose my voice,
we think the resources represented in the federal
agencies is a wonderful foundation for the digital public Library of America.
We are so anxious to make our collections available.
We have worked with the national archives and the Smithsonian.
We have worked with IMLS
and look forward to working with everyone who has
contributions to make to this important effort. Thank you. [Applause]
Thank you so much and thank you to Dr. Billington
and essentially for your leadership and offers of support
and your actual support on this effort.
We will see later on this afternoon a treat which is
examples from the beta Sprint.
One of them is entitled Digital collaboration for
America's national collections which joins the line very
of Congress and the national archives.
I understand it's not always the case of these three
agencies. We are hopeful for all of that
and all you have done and will do.
A second report from Washington is from the DPLA, Susan Hildreth.
She has been a champion through this project
and all manner of public libraries including small and rural libraries
and in many respects helped us identify the newest member of the steering committee.
Susan is currently the director of the IMLS which is in
many respects yet another piece of amazing foundation that supports museums
and libraries in the digitization effort.
Thank you and good morning everyone.
I think in this audience,
possibly everybody hear me know what IMLS is just to make
sure I'm going to review a little bit about what we do.
We are the Institute of Museum and Library services.
We are a federal executive agency that is responsible for grantmaking.
We distribute the federal dollars for libraries and museums
in the United States but as time as the dawn
we are fairly young agency.
We were established in the late 1990s and have taken on other roles,
particularly data collection, evaluation,
policy development and leadership in the field.
We think about the role we play with our federal
partners, Library of Congress, Smithsonian,
we have great access to our nation's museums and libraries
and we provide a distribution network to the on ramp up
our digital library highway.
We are excited to be part of this adventure. Again,
I would like to thank the Berkman center for Internet
and Society, our funders, the Sloan foundation
and we are very happy to be here today.
Some of the key issues we are discussing today
and in the future are what should this DPLA be?
I think we have made great progress and will continue to do so.
Who can participate? How can you participate?
How will a pizza stained as a public resource?
From the IMLS point of view
and from all of the work many of us have done,
I have another question to think about today is which products of the previous work
can we use in constructing a digital public Library of America this is a key interest for IMLS.
We have made a number of investments in digitization all
around our nation. We do have federal resources.
We are interested in how DPLA is moving forward so we can
make strategic investments to support the digitization efforts.
I think as you have heard a little bit today from
Deanna-- and digital library research development and demonstration projects.
We know in the years that followed other federal state
and private funders join in supporting these efforts
and in the mid- 1990s the newly created IMLS joined the
effort with our first digitization project grant awards in 1998.
Our agencies range of digital library investments has expanded dramatically.
Some of the things we have been doing includes hundreds
of digitization projects ranging from the specialized and focused --
and a great partnership with the University of Illinois
to aggregate the metadata.
You will see that in the Beta Sprint project this
afternoon. We have been funding projects
and building tools that enhance how people use digital content.
We have supported the advance of digital libraries such as the ongoing multi- partaner project managed at the
University of Michigan.
We have supported collaborations at all levels with a wide variety of partners
and particularly the statewide digitization projects that
are now in existence in more than 40 states.
We developed applied research ranging from the
examination of the online information seeking behavior of teens to investigations for the best methods for
preserving instructional video games.
We are committed to training a high-class quality
workforce who can become our navigators of the 21st century.
I think our library schools are doing a great job in moving us forward
and needs additional assistance in developing 21st century digitally competent librarians
and that is a key role for IMLS.
We're also providing support for national conversations.
Important to the future of digital libraries,
a good example is an upcoming meeting of experts
and leaders to map out a blueprint for the public library
role in the emerging Digital Public Library of America.
We will hold back in November at the Los Angeles public
Library thanks to the work
and collaboration of the library. These ongoing
and early investments by IMLS
and others have advanced digital library practices in
ways that might not have been possible without
coordinated and sustained support. What is our next step?
I think we are at a critical point of moving forward in this world.
What kinds of new organizations do we need to provide the services that have been provided previously?
I think we want to recognize we have a lot of information available for our designers
and builders of DPLA to develop there efforts.
We have developed a critical mass of digitized collections already.
We have elements of existing digital library
infrastructure. We have developed systems that tools, models and standards and policies.
We have organizations who  were willing to build and maintain and monitor
and support these digital collections.
One other resource we have available to all of us to help
jumpstart the DPLA is we have a record of journals, conference proceedings,
reports of 20 years of national
and international discussions on what digital libraries
should be, who can participate and how they can be sustained.
From the IMLS point of view where we have invested in our
aggregate good efforts all across the country
and we would really like to have our efforts be
sustainable and available to be evaluated
and have the impact on our users,
we just have a couple of lessons learned we wanted to
share. In digitization it's difficult to go at it alone.
Collaboration is key to long-term success.
The traditional understanding of the relationship between
information providers and consumers is changing
and both can benefit from working together in new ways.
Digital libraries have demonstrated there potential to
reduce administrative barriers to information access .
We have a long way to go.
How can they transform individuals and community lives.
We also want to make sure we follow some of the key
principles we have been following at IMLS.
We try to make sure our grantees follow interoperability
and preservation of digital information resources.
We had a discussion about that yesterday about persistence
and how if someone is involved in DPLA we must have the
responsibility to take care of that data.
We want to address rights for access and the use of content. Make sure programs
and services are sustainable
and find new ways to measure the impact to our public.
Another question we are dealing with is this sounds great
but what is the difference going to be for a person who
is going on the web and wants to find information?
I know we can find the answers to that question.
I am particularly pleased to be here because I hope that
IMLS can support our efforts in the future. [Applause]
If I might briefly draw out two things you mentioned.
One is one way in which I think the entire DPLA project
can be successful is not just if it brings support into a
single force but if it creates a platform that allows for
better coordination of the funding you
and others are doing into libraries
and institutions a part of this,
if what we do is do more with what we are already doing
and coordinate better, I think we will have succeeded.
I think that's an important initial concept. Second, you mentioned the excitement
and possibilities of having a new crowd of librarians.
The archivist mentioned our friends at Symonds in Boston
have a room set aside for people are watching this being streamed to Simmons.
Since we have started this process the number of library students and people
and library schools have raised their hand.
It's encouraging and exciting.
The last report from Washington. This is David Ferriero,
the archivist of the United States.
He is leading this institution we are in.
He comes from the New York public Library.
Before that he was the director of the MIT director of libraries and at Duke.
It is extremely fitting you are a host today
and thank you so much for all you have done
and we are looking forward to listening to you.
Citizens, have your records been scheduled? -- Susan,
have your records been scheduled?
Yes [Indiscernible].
How many of you, this is your first visit to this building?
I need to tell you who we are because we are the best-kept secret in town.
The national archives is the nation's record keeper.
We are the record keepers for the 275 federal agencies and the White House
and we provide courtesy storage for all the records of
Congress. We opened our doors in 1935.
FDR described it as his baby.
It's amazing of what we have in terms of records before
1935 have survived, exposed to fire, theft and flood
and exposed to horrible situations.
The story of records being stored in the garage at the
White House during the Rutherford B. Hayes administration.
We have records that start with the Continental Congress.
The allegiance signed at Valley Forge.
With 44 facilities from Anchorage Alaska to Atlanta Georgia.
I love this debate between the Library of Congress
and the British Library about size, get over it.
We have 12 billion pages of textual records.
40 million photographs.
600,000 artifacts in the presidential libraries
and the largest growing collection of electronic content.
Billions of electronic records right now in our custody.
The presidential records act which is one of the sets of
laws the government recognized electronic mail in 1996 so
we started collecting e-mail from the Reagan administration.
20 million e-mails from the Clinton administration in 210
million e-mails from the George Bush administration.
As the president likes to tell me,
not one of those is mine.
Our customers are researchers and genealogists
and veterans and the general public, Congress
and the White House using our records all the time.
I have an alter your motive.
My reason for being so passionate about the digital
library is I want every piece of this collection digitized.
I wanted available to the world. [Applause].
As you heard from John I have been in this business for long time
and I can still remember at Duke University faculty
members coming to me complaining because their students
were doing all their research online.
I can't remember discussions with my librarians about how we were going to get him to use the paper material.
Get over it.
What can we do to get that stuff digitized.
How can we facilitate the creation of it.
I am convinced if it's not online it doesn't exist.
That is why I am so interested in this project.
Let me tell you a little bit about that massive amount of material we have.
We have done such a small fraction of that content.
We have established commercial partnerships with ancestry.com and family search
and genealogists are one of our biggest markets.
We have done a small percentage of passenger lists, pension files, the civil
and revolutionary war records to get that material in people's hands.
The massive amount of material we have has caused us to
be rather creative in ways of creating new opportunities.
Some of you have may have seen the citizen's archivist
program that has been launched through the national archives.
Soon you will see the dashboard giving out opportunities
for the people to get involved in helping us process records.
We are also using them to help digitize our records.
We have a civil war conservation Corps in this building
working on civil war records preparing them for digitization.
We've got -- that has about 5000 primary sources that are
loaded with lesson plans
and a facility for teachers to talk to each other
and share lesson plans and share uses of material.
We are trying in all different kinds of angles to make as
much of our content available as possible.
I want to give you a concrete example of the power of
this kind of digital collection.
I was at the New York public Library for five years.
When I was being interviewed I had to sign a nondisclosure statement.
I spent five years working with Google
and we digitized about a million books from the New York public Library collection.
I slowly saw the power of researchers having access to that broad body of information
and how it has already transformed scholarship.
I have a wonderful in-house storage. In December 2009,
the President issued an executive order announcing the
declassification center at the national archives which
gave me the mandate to review 400 million pages of classified content
and with a mandate to release as much is possible on two
criteria, weapons of mass is corruption
and national security could be used to keep the classified.
It's a process we have launched working with agencies who
have equities in the content.
We have reviewed over a million pages
and have released of those that have gone through the
full analysis have released 91% to the open shelves.
We are making great progress.
The oldest in these records go back to World War I and 1917. In April,
I am pleased the CIA finally caved on the six oldest
documents. They were German formulas for secret ink.
Leon Panetta before he left the CIA had a big press
conference announcing the fact that he is releasing these documents.
What he didn't say is he released them because my staff used Google books
and discovered these formulas have been published in 1931.
[Laughter].
That's what it's all about.
Thank you. [Applause]
Another of the exciting things I think that lies ahead
and in many different use cases
and stories we will hear about.
It's not surprising this room is filled not just filled
with the information business but professional historians.
Historians of researchers that are here because there is
a sense of opportunity for specific projects
and research that we simply can't do today.
Another sign of this project is the speakers have kept to
their time so we actually have time for discussion in this report from Washington.
There are microphones on either side.
I would remind you we are in a place where you are being recorded.
For those of you who haven't been here do need to carve
out some time to get up into the rotunda to see the
Declaration of Independence, the Constitution and Bill of Rights.
There are samples of records from the archives
and in the special gallery there is a wonderful exhibit called its cooking uncle Sam
and it's about the government's role in telling you what to eat.
I would like to acknowledge my mother who is here today.
I'm doing that because it relates to the food exhibit.
She has is in charge of the first ladies let's move initiative.
I am hoping to drag her into the digital library as well.
There must be a question by now.
I have no other relatives in the audience to announce.
IMX from Drexel -- I am Mick from Drexel.
-- I think there are different technical challenges with
putting stuff online [Indiscernible]?
You are looking at three people who don't know how to do that.
[Laughter]. Public-private partnership.
It depends on how you define discoverability.
One of the things Josh Greenberg taught me when he came
to the New York public Library is we have a history of building digital libraries
and expecting people to find us so let's think about the people and likes get our stuff out there.
Using YouTube and things like that to get the content into the eyes of the people.
It's a huge problem for me because our records are so massive and complex.
A new learning experience here is that kids today can't read cursive
and all of my old records are in cursive so one of the
wonderful things on the dashboard you will see is an opportunity for us to help us transcribe.
Last week I transcribed my first document. I wanted to address accessibility.
I think in your question we speak about accessibility
you're talking about making material available to be seen or identified,
but I also think accessibility is a much broader issue in
terms of making the great content we have available to
all kinds of individuals with accessibility challenges
and those could be visually impaired,
language challenges, so accessibility is really important.
I agree with you that if you have a lot of stuff out
there and nobody can find it, what is the use?
One of the things that IMLS is interested in supporting is different strategies
and platforms to effective discovery.
There are many other entities in Washington
and even privately that would be willing to support
development of those kinds of platforms or strategies.
That is a very good example for me
and better discovery tools about how IMLS can help use
federal dollars to support this initiative,
but I would just like to echo,
we haven't talked all that much about accessibility,
but I'm assuming I think it is a key priority that all of
our information is available in many different formats.
There's another aspect of this,
this is a lesson I learned at MIT a round serendipity
and how we make it possible to have that same serendipity
experience because that is where discovery comes from.
I will hand the microphone back to you.
I am Nancy and I'm the director of the Smithsonian institution libraries.
Since the Smithsonian was mentioned as one of the three
agencies trying to develop,
I wanted to mention to the audience we also are very
interested in participating in the DPLA with our 137
million objects, since we are talking numbers today.
This is a good competition.
I have to follow that up by saying 124 million of them
are natural history specimens.
How many mosquitoes we want to have at the DPLA is a question.
I think you have seen in the past that the secretary said
he also wants to share the Smithsonian's riches with the
nation and the world in many ways and we already have 6.
4 million digitized objects
and are trying to go forward as fast as we can.
We are in a unique position to pull in museum library and archived objects together
and to help figure out how that can best be done for the DPLA and for the nation.
I am eager to continue to cooperate
and share our riches with all of you.
[Applause].
Thank you.
We've had extraordinary support from your colleague
and the Smithsonian has been very actively involved
and we look for much more to come as we digitized the
insects and many other things.
I have a question about the statement regarding the CIA
documents. My brother and I have had conversations
and is rocket science work for the military.
We've had conversations about reverse engineering
and the dangers of fat.
I was curious -- dangers of that. [Indiscernible]
I don't want to give the impression the archives of the
United States has the authority to release.
The authority given to me in the executive order is to
give the agencies around the table to review the content
to ensure it is really classified. It was the CIA who released it, not the national archives.
I just facilitated the process.
Do you anticipate more?
As I said, we have done a million so far.
It has to be done by December 31, 2013.
I should also tell you in this room we had two open forms
for the public to advise us on which records are of the
most interest so we could get some citizen participation
to help us prioritize. I hosted both of those meetings.
The room was evenly split in both cases,
the Kennedy assassination conspiracy and UFOs. [Laughter]
As you mentioned, I'm from the British Library
and delighted to be here but won't even get into
arguments about size. They are disadvantages of scale.
It's like turning a big oil tanker
and whatever direction you want to go and it's always too slow.
Those of you who have smaller institutions, sometimes that can be a major advantage.
I'm really delighted to be here
and thank you all for inviting me.
This happened to coincide with the visit to the states so
I was delighted to stay on here today.
Like the Library of Congress,
we are a library of the world
and for the world so we share your aspirations to open up
our great collections of all cultures
and languages to the world. We have digitized a lot.
We have got a lot of boutiques
and shops that there is a disconnect and opportunistic but nevertheless
we want to make a digital library.
One of the challenges is what is the difference between
the digital library and a wonderful but confusing
and if you like random set of resources.
I think that is one of the challenges that we need to face.
I think public-private partnerships have been mentioned.
I think we in the UK because of our history
and partnership of these things,
I know you will hear from Jill Cousins.
We have brought some coherence bringing brought from the
European context through the European Library library
which will be an aggregate of libraries of Europe into
the broader cultural Museum.
We have just opened up all of our metadata on our CC0 license.
It was a braver step then perhaps you might -- in part
because we have a particular government that requires me to earn money.
It's not always a comfortable place to be so we said we
don't think that's right so we opened up the 16 million
of metadata to the world.
We have got everything happening in the most extraordinary way.
I suppose another lesson is you have no idea what this is
going to be used for. You can't plan for it
and it will be infinitely more creative the wider this thing gets.
I think metadata is a key consideration with this.
I think we have done a lot of work
and are beginning a long journey on what we label.
Digital curators and modern librarians,
I think that is a challenge we all share.
People as comfortable with large data text
and all of those things,
as with perhaps our traditional services.
I can give you many examples of what we digitized.
There is much more to go.
We intend to go as far as we can from a variety of sources.
It's often said the UK is probably the bridgehead between
North America and mainland Europe.
I would like to suggest that we are probably a good stopping off point
and if there are opportunities perhaps in this program we
would be delighted to host something in London at the
British Library as you take this journey forward.
We are part of the journey with you and I am delighted to be here today. [Applause]
We will probably take you up on that kind offer.
I should note one other thing you didn't break about what
should have is some of the research coming out of the
British Library in terms of how young people use information.
One of the reasons I think you have that serendipity
and wonderful things issue have come to understand the
concept but if we make available the tools and metadata,
people will do amazing things with it.
My name is John Mayer for the center for legal computer construction.
To use your imagination, it's 2016
and older collections have been digitized,
I am assuming this will only take five years.
I've heard a lot of excitement for that process
and for the science and how are going to do that.
What does society get? How does society
and crew for change once that is in place?
What is the science fiction of the DPLA?
I can speak for myself.
If we assume that people benefit from having access to information resources,
they can make better decisions for themselves.
They can understand where they have come from
and possibly a better direction.
They can understand world cultures.
I think what we have been trying to do -- who want to use
them in any way they want it's what we have talked about
with libraries my whole career.
We've talked about wanting to get these materials out to
people. We finally have a mechanism for doing that.
I don't know for me it isn't any more than that,
just making it available. Most of the resources
and public institutions are they are because Americans
have paid for them. It seems only right to share them.
For me, it is creating better informed citizenry.
The records here should be used to hold our government accountable for their actions
and for us to be able to understand our history.
We should be learning from our history.
The only way you can do that is to have access to the records
and people don't have that kind of access right now.
I am hoping we create a more informed citizenry. I personally think it's an amazing opportunity as my
colleagues have echoed.
I also think if everything is digitized,
I think as a practicing public Library
and the question comes to mind,
what happens to our physical facility?
Even if we may be aggregating
and curating data for our customers,
do we still have a place for people to gather?
I think by providing all of that information
and the empowerment of that information to our citizens
it will create an even greater need
and desire for people to work together.
As we have heard from the British Library,
the stuff it is out there
and people may be related in the virtual
and physical world, but I think it is a very exciting
and liberating future for our communities and citizens.
I think the other question I have is,
if for going to have all of this data out there, we must have connectivity to homes
and libraries in schools.
I think the more we make this content available people will understand
and adopt because they want to be there
and know what is happening.
I think it is a great hallmark for the future.
We have had a question session,
but you may have noticed a lot of that has taken the form of testimonials
and it's wonderful to see the support expressed from the
Smithsonian as well as from these three institutions represented on stage
and it's great that -- has just invited us all to London.
We accept.
The point I want to make is when we consider what we
should name this thing,
one of these suggestions was a national digital library
and it was rejected because there is nothing
nationalistic about this at all.
We may go from the boutique phase to the Wal-Mart phase.
Getting bigger means going international.
The -- wanted to be here. He says he is with us.
We have Jill Cousins and the European digital library.
These expressions of support from lots of different US
institutions as well as everyone scattered around the
country especially public libraries in small towns.
What this represents is a movement that has nothing
nationalistic about it but goes back to the international
Republic of letters that was dreamt of in the period of enlightenment.
I hope when getting his feeling we can make happen what
was a utopian dream at the founding of this country.
That sounds a little hiatus, but I I couldn't resist. [Applause]
I hope you will join me in thanking ever speakers. We have had an amazing group come together. Thank you.
[Applause]